want to get the one up and your
opponent's when ultra street fighter 4
launches this June Capcom community
manager and street fighter pro David
Hines gives us his tips and favorite
combos for ultras 5 you characters
here's what he's got to say about to
Khafre so if i press let's stick with
back forward lighting the ground in
version if I prints light punch it makes
it go backwards I was like a little a
little faint so if your opponent tries
to react to this move you can you can
kind of faint it make it safe right pull
away from your opponent so r you might
be tempted to upper cut it but by doing
this you'll make them think twice on top
of all of that she's got the X versions
of all of these foods let's just see
what they look like okay that turns into
a pro which is really cool
it's odd combo to this is what you call
call her combo ultra nice you can combo
into it as you can see quite easily from
that but on top of that she's got a
really defensive play style she can kind
of use her attacks like this to you know
slowly chip away at her opponent again
she's got a stinger attack and she's got
lots of target combos and the ability to
air pro she's a really unique character
and then let's not forget the chicken
combo into her ultra tube
so awesome every would you say I mean
and then share this one combo there
because I hit you a particular favorite
to do it's a preview got something else
I guess my favorite of the cadbury is
the ability to combo into a super yeah
so that's cool i really like that so if
you just explain that one briefly just
so what I did is I jumped in with a
heavy attack and then went straight into
a crouching medium hunch and then from
Crouching million punch I did crouching
medium kick into her stabbing move which
is a gossip response repeatedly some
what I do is I think counsel got into
super while she's running along you have
time to hold back again right and get
your charge to the charge motion which
is hold back for two seconds yeah
forward back forward and punch